after 2016 elections when Democrats
start saying that the social media is to
blame for Trump's victory
Mark Zuckerberg the creator of Facebook
just thought that was ridiculous it was
absurd to him that Facebook could have
had that role but you saw the pressure
was so intense on Zuckerberg between
2016 and 2020 by 2020 many
senior Executives had come from not just
American intelligence and security
agencies but also from British ones
and there's always a justification for
it because these are people that were
good at doing investigations these are
people that understand what's going on
in places like Myanmar where Facebook
had been abused to contribute to attacks
on the rohingya there's always some sort
of justification for it but you start to
see the capturing of Facebook and
Twitter by us and UK intelligence
Services ostensibly retired officials
but again if you believe what people in
the intelligence Services tell you
nobody ever really retires